I joined the idol game during auditions
in Savannah and now they're in Milwaukee
hopefully they're hearing voices that
are a lot more pleasing than Katy
Perry's Doug and nugget is that you seen
me naked she's a terrible yapper because
she's so tiny and she hasn't she feels
like she has nothing to protect her
besides her size the bark besides her
bar and she's become becoming worse with
time yeah this is up two of five for the
idol judges but Lionel's new favorite
artist a billy Eilish and her SNL homage
to his 1986 music video I would thought
that was so cool and of course when I
put out there that you know next
generation on the ceiling when she took
that left step to the to the wall I said
oh my god and then of course the wall
came down do you know how hard that is
meanwhile we've just shared a major life
moment onstage with some lucky fans
delivering an epic gender-reveal last
saturday night's first of all it's a
green piece of paper congratulations
you're having an alien it handed me a
package I guess from the doctor's office
I saw the chart the health of the baby
this is way too much information
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]